la suite du parking faut rester dans le
parking et je vous ai laissé le meilleur
pour la fin
je suis tombé sur une perle les chéris
un mec de ouf très très nerveux
regarde
[Musique]
il est interdit de fumer dans le
portugal a annoncé aujourd'hui pour
composer le sida monsieur bah justement
il ya un parking qui fonctionne
il ya deux sicav la joie de cigares
l'asim ii non mais ça va pas ça on le
dit un soin il entend jamais rien et
estiment eux ils croient tout permis
c'est bon quoi j'avais monsieur vous
avez n'ouvrir oui pourquoi ils crient
comme celui-ci là on sait bien d'où sort
allô oui monsieur vous pouvez ouvrir
s'il vous plaît je ne trouve pas très
aimable
moi non plus je vais pas être très mal
et je vais appeler monsieur krawczyk si
vous continuez ce qu'ils font ou
d'origine allemande
ouvrez la porte et sa petite soeur
bonjour monsieur ya pas de bonjour
monsieur tient très bien qui je suis
comme par hasard on se retrouve à
beaucoup pouvoir maintenant laisse moi
rire
ce s'il vous plaît qu'est ce que tu veux
la praille assez complète je suis en
clientèle mais bon là tu comprends ça en
clientèle at réalisé vrai la barrière
d'accord mais est ce qu'on peut se
parler deux minutes tu penses que tu me
dois quand même deux minutes vous écoute
pourquoi tu as disparu c'est pas le
temps j'ai pas le temps c'est ma mère
qui m'a tant la mise encore faire le
bout avec ta lettre tu me la sortie 15
fois tu avais alors dans ce cas là tu
prends ma barrows à oui mais je sais oui
mais toi tu bois tu combien de fois
comme toi tu as dit que tu avais on
aimerait que tu as bégard et avait
rendez vous avec des bd un défi de joie
c'est un transport services j'ai pas
vraiment service on se pose des
questions sur la machine
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent à l'autre là tu
peux lui dire terme et sa tronche et à
la halo de carrière vraiment sûr c'est
pas un bug cd petitesse de qu'on fait
parce qu'aujourd'hui tu sais mais qu'on
dit dans un monde aujourd'hui la machine
absolument remplacer d'accord moi
j'étais
dans la boulangerie pour entrer en fait
au bout d'un feu argentine sous s'est
battu comme étienne choquette le
boulanger lui me dit oui
on n'a plus besoin de toi
les chouquettes je peux les faire
moi j pas loin
tout ce motif louis la machine et on tue
comme julie écoute moi bien mon petit
gars qu'est ce qu'ils sont mais lui ce
que je veux dire c'est coûteux je sais
pas qui tu connais tu connais jean
michel fougasse ils marchent ou est-ce
que tu connais eric roy sont nous avons
[Musique]
comme ça et
allez oui dites moi je me trouve à
marboeuf là j'ai un espèce de malades
qui n'ouvre pas les portes étaient
coincés et j'arrive pas à sortir s'il
vous plaît je suis pas il ya un cas
social qui c'est là derrière de cosmed
lui mais c'est qui jeta sa grand mère at
you la montrer comment il parle mais on
t'a pistolet pour pour faire son taf ou
c'est moi je te demande juste quelque
chose
les excuses j'allais chercher je veux
terminer sur ce magazine
d'accord je vais tenir mais si je viens
c'est normal et les ventes peuvent
s'étonner je vais venir et femmes
détenus toi tu poche il se passe quelque
chose là vous pouvez essayer de voir où
il est critique
écoutez moi bien monsieur oui je vous
faire une révélation
ouais je dis tiens krawczyk mais vous
êtes qui je ne peux pas vous le dire
ayé moi je peux pas sortir là vous êtes
gentils géo pascal chic
allô monsieur oui fait ce qui vous dit
s'il vous plaît quoi par exemple un émoi
de cigares et une boîte de tictacs et
attention des bigots si joie de type
taxi 60e jour s'est arraché pour ta
gueule mais c'est quoi la caisse qui se
passe je ne détiens d'accord bien sous
les ordres tu vas dire la machine
la machine sera toujours en dessous de
la ligne antonio dessus ni sur de sucre
comme tu veux
leur message est d'accord et tu tu fumes
tu bois disco squad
chez nous là il à meetic tac
t'es servi hélas aucune chance j'écrase
chic
dis moi que tu m'aimes je te dire en
face ouvre la barrière je vais venir te
voir il va enfin d'accord alors m
jetons mais moi je peux te faire cadeau
pour tablettes
merci les schémas
merci à toutes les personnes à du
parking ar
voilà du parquet et bien sûr et ils ont
tous signé en plus autorisation et merci
à eux mêmes quand chic la suite
quantique ou pas et la suite qu'on
voulait encore la semaine ba ouai bof
ferrisat il ya une suite bizarrement je
vais vous dire la vérité c'est ce qu'il
a été garé sa voiture il a pris les
escaliers
non mais n'ont jamais revu et on a été
obligé d'aller le voir et de le signer
mais pour qui si une autorisation vous
dire celui-là et des filets et alors